man this team mean the world man we put
in a lot of hard work Blood Sweat and
Tears each and every day to get to this
moment and man my offensive line they do
a heck of a job each and every day you
know coach H leading away for those guys
you know and just making sure that
everybody's prepared each and every day
you know allowing me to have a clean
pocket to be able to get the ball to my
weapons you know it's just a blessing to
be able to have and I I thank them each
and every day for it I'm going have to
take them out somewhere uh sometime soon
the the wide receivers get a shout out
Roma dun Rome where are you get over
here Rome I want to give you a shout out
Rome is from Las Vegas from Las Vegas
huge night
tonight what did it mean to be
performing in front of 60 of your
friends and family oh it's a blessing um
you know I'm such a great supporter
system you know from my mom my my pops
and all my aunts and uncles my cousins
you know my friends and family that come
here to support me in this team and you
know that's that's that's just the half
of it I got a whole village you know
supporting me husky Nation supporting me
this team everybody so we're blessed
well congratulations to all of you and
last question Michael this is a
championship moment but how do you think
this team can move forward so it's not
the only Championship moment for you
this year man we have such a mature team
you know we we understand this is this
is a big accomplishment for us and we're
super excited but we know we going to
have more work to do and we're going to
be ready for whenever that time comes
and uh man we just going to continue to
enjoy this moment you know we just so
blessed man and I got to say man they
tried to write us off but we ain't right
back we ain't right back
yeah